we have in the Bronx is pretty tough
area has helped shape me to be a pretty
tough guy on the court as well but
Kimber was a velvet sword by that I mean
you cut you
you stood feeling he didn't trash talk
he just played I'm not sure he's tall
enough to ride the rides when he goes to
Disneyland and he's the real thing I kid
out of heart bigger anybody I can throw
not playing in the park
he's almost kicking up the court that
was small people always say oh he can't
do his candy back and in this candidate
I'm just like why can't why can't take
here that's why it's called March
Madness in 2010-11 you know I knew it
would be a lot of my shoulders and know
try and leave these freshmen and
sophomores so we looked up to him I
barely thought season started we wasn't
rank everybody kind of felt disrespected
offseason wrote us off he went not sixty
eighteen which was ridiculous no to fuel
to the fire
well UConn was coming off a very
mediocre season and you know Kemba
Walker was a player who I won't say he
underachieved his first couple years but
he wasn't anything real special he
definitely had a chip on his shoulder
from what the reporters saying about our
team he was just extremely determined
for our team to do something
would trickle down on all of us we got
to number four in the country and then
we got into Biggie's play and no things
started to go a little downhill from
there we ended the season losing four
out of five finished nine and the
biggies first game and the Big East
tournament played the ball to start off
at noon on Tuesday in Madison Square
Park
I mean it's cavernous it's empty little
depressing early in the day we felt
disrespected a little bit from laya
frontcourt left-wing goes to the
baseline pitch and that's game against
Georgetown we just saw what point went
out once again down late those guys
Walker
fantastic good
he's gonna take the last shot
don't went into my step back in from
that point on I mean you've seen it on
the
Walker
Stucky
goofball and then went in and pray
I've never seen coach Cal that excited I
was hilarious jumping up light there
then to compose himself realize that
he's changing do it him it's a big
moment you've got history I turn to my
sisters as we walked up closer we got
some and you God wince again I was
fighting off the naysayers who kept
saying you're gonna get Titan you got to
play Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday that's too much I really felt
that my kids were feeding on the idea
that they have no idea who we are we're
just getting better in this thing
Kappa house to go I gained five days
five wins there was a broad consensus
that UConn was spent they had shot all
their bullets in New York that yeah
maybe they could win a game or two maybe
sneaking to the sweet 16 but nobody was
looking at UConn saying there they go
now we all felt like man if we can win
the Big East like that is no way these
teams in the other conferences can beat
us
napier little show and go haha
touch-free season in the big news hey
we're not supposed to be this good
you guys okay Cincinnati which is a
really rough game anyone to tie up guys
we went for anybody on the baby sick
trust in his head
I'll tell you my backing
sweet 16
they doing a great job up until one
Jamaal Franklin Mont me Jamaal Franklin
number 21
a little right shoulder bone you got to
go to 50 intimidating he's a - New York
City's invaded by too much on that one
Nolan
I was just in the different zone
the monster ticker treated
Wow there Williams second half he came
on I want to move
Walker fadeaway oh the time was going
down no got all three behind one of the
guys drove and found that guy Jamel home
from kiss hated three I felt the win on
my fingers when it got past my hands and
I looked back I thought for sure it was
good with his trip I just remember the
ball game I'm like man it's my turn I
just like it's my turn
how to feel that pain I just knew that
balls going I'm kind of will to the
right left this for the win
for the break we missed 24 no game over
goes back to the final four
I try to tell those guys you know just
try to embrace it because it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity
who plays bigger than his size he's not
afraid he has a chip on his shoulder
about who he is he was the guy that you
had to really guard terrific play
that's up
for so hard those guys may run after run
that game
just stuck with the game and pulled out
a bigger possession here for the Huskies
tonight gives it up Liggins
the game
and UConn has done it again it's time
seven madness
he takes it inside the file he's heading
to the line it will be important for him
to make one or two in this game it was a
pretty rough first happen above the game
that one rattles out Smith has he wait I
mean obviously it wasn't a pretty game
you know both teams really defended well
getting a locker room and coach start
throwing stuff
good news clip 20 points we just want
the kind of pace we need to be playing
and we just make a few adjustments and
making tripe like quick please upset we
went out and we play like that play man
that's a stolen lamb on his way
bendiga space rock lays up and it goes
win the Maui Invitational they go 5 for
5 at the biggies 5 days and in the
six-game run through
I love it that was our 11th win whole
season man it was just so surreal
you see something like Kemba Walker and
and what UConn did we don't forget that
most time like 30 people become what
they can be we did
the year if somebody was that tell me
we're going to play the first night the
biggest friend of man going win that
championship yeah I'll probably it was
like a movie
yeah he's going back
it was unbelievable